mais en effet new york apprend désormais
à vivre sans le world trade center et
c'est la ruée vers les objets souvenirs
comme le monde ce reportage de philippe
gassot et christian tu
à times square en plein week-end de
septembre on aura jamais vu si peu de
monde les vendeurs à la sauvette ont
connu des périodes plus fastes c'est
vrai que le touriste se fait rare il est
souvent choqué il c'est quelque part
qu'il a vécu un événement exceptionnel
et qu'il était là mais il veut quand
même rentré chez lui avec la preuve avec
quelque chose à montrer à ceux qui ont
eu peur pour lui
on vend beaucoup de cartes postales des
tours jumelles oui oui ça se vend bien
ceux qui marchent aussi mais c'est plus
cher ce sont les tours sous bulle made
in hong kong qui risque bien de n'être
plus fabriqués dans quelques temps le
modèle en métal ça se vend pas mal et la
bulle ça tombe bien aussi
la première c'est à 5,2 à 99 et la bulle
à 6,99
la police habituellement nombreuses dans
les endroits touristiques de new york a
changé de rôle depuis le drame les
problèmes ce n'est plus le stationnement
où les pickpockets
l'action est plus psychologique
notre rôle c'est d'essayer de veiller à
la sécurité de donner au public
l'impression de sécurité de rassurer les
gens
ce qui se vend très bien aussi ce sont
les drapeaux tout le monde en veut à
voir avec soin la bannière étoilée s'est
montré son attachement et sa volonté de
résister au pire
mais fabriquer à la hâte pour une vente
immédiate le t-shirt du drame que l'on
s'arrache à canal street discutable mais
bien compréhensible
c'est un des moments les plus forts de
l'histoire de l'amérique et dans 20 ans
je pourrai dire à mes enfants que
j'étais ici et que j'ai vécu la tragédie
ne cherchait aucune morale dans tout
cela new york n'a jamais manqué une
occasion de se faire de l'argent un
signe évident de retour à la normale